walk him to this video this is a rare
occurrence I just played the same guy
again that are just lost in the previous
game due to a Muslim so he I think he
has managed to play one game while I was
doing the post-game analysis and he won
that to his lucky day probably ok so the
king's indian classical bionet attack
King h8 is a crazy line that I had
studied back in the day when I was
regularly playing the Kings Indian Oh
interesting this is an interesting mix
of lines and ok let's prepare five not
quite sure office it's in any way a good
mix but let's see what happens normally
the bishop assume is posted on on on a
three in this structure ok I'm getting
some pressure on ok it is taking I
expected that the question is so what
Bishop takes or Luke tags i think Bishop
Jake's he might try to take and plain
ip5 just trying to go to c7 but Darrell
if all is hanging so he I'm not sure
that it can do that so easily maybe he
needs to spend a move to him to get some
protection for you for not sure maybe
you can play play that takes takes 9 p-5
takes on your 492 what's wrong it's not
clear that 97's some threatening much
can go nitey 736 but so not not not
really so convincing ok here i can also
you can just take here this one-on-one
good move
now 94-95 is just probably just good for
black yeah this looks weird getting into
Bishop f5 and stuff like that mmm see
how should I do it Bishop f5 mm-hm it's
not clear if it is some leading to
anything great i can also play that
night f5 to d4 and then Bishop f5 it
also gives me the additional idea to
take on d6 with the night if you should
capture now looks looks bit weird
actually to go here and just as I say it
looks beauty does it well this happened
in the game before as well I play so
many moves that I didn't expect yeah it
looks like pretty good piece play now
actually let's see mp4 or is this
mistimed should I just cover it for the
moment like with Queenie 7 I mean camera
if I've hmm maybe
so when the idea could be to even play
for opening up the long diagonal but
it's not so easily controlling you for
yeah that's very important of course
okay yeah I'm kickin so it should simply
play some news is applying stuff that I
don't expect any way 94 Bishop g5 wins
the exchange now I needs to play a 4
which is quite terrible maybe maybe he
needs to do some some tactics now rook
e1 or something not clear maybe okay
should be 5i Bishop g5 he actually has
got this check it's still probably a
probably something I could play it's got
the trick
you can also take b form and so not bad
at all or Bishop f5 threatening it
threatening Bishop g5 and stuff or
threatening on before and maybe do that
it's at least an interesting way to play
keeping it for protected from the moment
and keeping those options open I can
take now I'm Bishop g5 again hmm yeah we
might take with the rook here I don't
know now if captured default III okay
all right tricky
okay i can maybe really just take you
fri am possible yeah i really don't mind
that much i mean i've got the two
bishops I've got pressure against f2 eg5
is hanging I really don't think of any
problems here but I didn't see that
really okay just can also take here and
only six foot taking with the porn it's
not bad i threatening d5 he cannot move
the night so easily because of Bishop to
d3 okay as usual here some playing the
move I was just talking about us being
bad but hey well why me maybe you didn't
have anything better that's possible
okay so i can just take be five if there
is only a check on each time
Joe will be five is hanging and no not
so many moose night is 6am maybe but
I'll take I'll take everything here I
still may be 96 good i have about to
rock singing two rocks hanging i am
that's the main problem 96 i take f1 and
then threatening to take on f2 then in
addition to everything
I'm going to play move what is this the
white resides no no we resigned okay um
count through sauce very tricky so like
in this game that I had before I didn't
expect any of the moves but ok take so I
can also take with the pawn of course
but this looks interesting and because
it's just an active piece on d6 I've
done ok takes takes e4 I have 92 and
Bishop f5 if you had the computer
actually agrees my original idea was
this but then there's the check is that
there is no good response to that this
would be ok if not for taking check oops
and take down UFC 7 ok there for Bishop
f5 and tone or the comp give blacks a
slight slight advantage which probably
which is probably ok yeah after that
black is a clear advantage rook da tis
the computer will file it's maybe better
maybe oopsie 7s what the engine is
expecting that I would have played III
with an advantage ok so it's good for
black after all we're always giving
black almost upon advantage I am really
wasn't so sure how good it is but always
thought that the two bishops and the
good coordination should be should be
alright
and tiara Black is just winning a plus
five for black that's a lot this is some
way is completely tied up here with this
pieces this is also not helping really
96 I'm taking here which is important so
that I still attack on on c4 I think he
could have recaptured and then he will
get a 1 we get some material back this
is still good actually but the other
line what I played was really better so
I'm pretty a pretty clean Winnie at the
engine alright thanks for watching